hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play homesick
now there's another suggestion somebody
sent me a download link I said okay
here we go though stupid website maybe
sign up an account just to download it
which I didn't like but oh well so I
don't have any idea what this is about
don't know what I'm eating myself into
like the music though thank you very
nice how to play a D mousewheel F shift
Q escape find what you can deranged
killers enjoy hit challenge don't be
afraid to cross this one when he's
taunting you what the fresh light is
extremely visible if you're in danger
get out of sight and turn it off don't
stay in the same room for too long
you're never safe
how about even say for this room let's
see what happens I'm excited seems like
it's got some potential
[Music]
ten years ago my older brother his wife
and his best friend along with his
friend's wife and son were brutally
murdered in a house on the outskirts of
town
[Music]
the police never solved the crime all
they could find were chunks of the
victims flesh wrapped in candy wrappers
itty-bitty little killers okay the house
was demolished everyone soon forgot and
another home was built on the plot
purchased by a good friend of mine oh I
can skip is anyone home
yes deranged killers is home I'm willing
to bet hello the light switch doesn't
seem to be working
I think the power's out sheesh it is
dark in here as it is outside I'll just
turn on my light until I can get some
light in here oh wow it's a go I didn't
know it was gonna be like this oh okay
Oh interesting look at me I'm just a
pretty little girl mmm I have my flowing
skirt is this the end table is huge it's
so big painting huh I was not I was not
expecting this one I was uh looking at
this game know when I open the game so
but then again I know Nagi because
pixelized adventures like this but this
seems more reminiscent of old school why
is that interesting why am I talking to
myself you're going crazy lady I'm going
crazy who's a deranged killer
my goodness I was so worried wait
deliver
Oh mouse will to change action that's
right
ah ah okay that deranged killer popped
out of nowhere I'm so scared okay stairs
hey I know that sound effect ah but a
deranged car burger
I got a lamp bug off nurse you saw oh
good thing we're both so slow
oh no okay good I clicked outside the
game it's a small box oh wow
okay I'll I thought it was dead already
okay alright so yeah
the game window is much smaller than my
desktop so uh ah come on da ah come on
it wasn't my fault
exit else however how did he get so
whoosh close and that's about to happen
it's anyone home
okay what the hell huh I've been here
okay so if I can change the action that
means I can go from that to opening it
oh hold o goatse action going on here oh
god I'm so difficult
wait was there anything in there how
Louis as hard as opening that pickle
charlie haha
God okay so there is a deranged killer
it's gonna pop up in here well
okay so change the acting to opening you
do uh-huh there we go
I got a flimsy crowbar that was in a
medicine cabinet let me out why why was
it in the matter why a medicine cabinet
stay away from the door ain't killers
you know ghost oh they're psychotic her
evil in their dastardly ways t okay come
on come on
how did you go upstairs blue blue blue
look at that little stick figure no no
no and how stay right there
oh no don't you try it buddy I got my
eye on you tie your tie I'm a licensed
oh that might've been the only door huh
okay I don't even don't even try dark
dark double that damn dark there we go I
know if I can get away from these guys
in rooms yeah but that musics definitely
from SCP of some sort
oh no no oh no I'm gonna record don't go
away how that Mosin oh wow
how's I supposed to know come on come on
oh uh okay one more time I'll try huh
wha we're trying one more failure damn
dirty terrains killers all over the
place
popping up out of the shadows okay bling
blong it's damn dark as bad ten years
ago is anyone home okay go Toa oh wait
can I run I can't run shift that's right
oh my boobs are flop around all over the
place sorry excuse me Jimmy should have
worn a sports bra
there's jumped in come on hey Doc oh
come on open it with my epically strong
arms ha what it's not there baloney cuz
I'm on my own for this one at least I
can run huh oh look how I sprinted to
that door there was a foot away hmm I
don't think things are realistic to
equate that printing action to what else
what could possibly be a disk ape time
weighed down by my giant bazoombas okay
here we go alright moving forward okay
in the kitchen her bra turn on charge of
rock ah nothing
bollocks oh I should have opened the
cabinet in the beginning if we're gonna
be trapped red bats
run right I'm sorry that would mean that
would be odd me I apologize for that I
just got scared
so I can run past them if they're not in
Chase mode run run how am I supposed to
get away from these these guys I'm not
exactly sure okay open this what can I
open you aah aah
doubles jeez jeez Louise stop it these
douches need to ease up I don't have a
chance to actually do anything going up
the stairs Jase
jiminy Christmas all right so let me try
that door I tried the other one before
the crowbar somewhere that I need to get
again and don't know why I found the
first one in the medicine cabinet
nowhere else
oh honey don't guard ah ah ah man there
are quick
Oh turn off the light
Oh turn off the light when I need to get
away oh oh let me try that do this one
more try let me give this one more try
and if I can prove to you how to beat
the game that means when you guys played
you can enjoy it come here come here
come here I'm gonna getcha
come on strangle you I'm gonna kill the
deranged killers it's a twist
I was deranged killer all along but then
who was phone okay anybody home geez
into cooking draw Oh super opening
action huh nope okay try here if I turn
off my light as I am opening something
work dirt I wouldn't think that the
loading okay here we go
no one could see me when I'm doing this
get to the door get through the damn
door damn it
hey man how the hell am I gonna get away
from them they're very persistent am i
going through the door how Keegan's
they're very ding damn persistent I do
not know as to how I should get away
from them come on he got he did the B
was behind me and then he was in front
of me Oh beat this game maybe just maybe
I should get the hell out of the house
maybe instead of going into the house I
go out of the house huh maybe maybe I
don't know all right so all right that's
enough for now so thank you all so much
for watching click the download link in
the description to get the file for
yourself and play for yourself I don't
know how to play it I'm terrible at this
game but you guys could be better so
thank you all so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye
Roma crisis don't screw this up get up
yeah jingle bells
go to hell [ __ ] get out of my way
read or part to heaven is up trouble
stayed upright nailed it